Let's be Frank here,
I have no uses about democracy the way we know it. It's
may be coming to an end.
But I always emphasize in this book,
in other books,
that democracy are not just the written rules,
democracy are also.
There is no democracy without unwritten
silent rules that you have to obey and so on.
And this is simply breaking down
in the United States.
You have now a guy
who openly formalates disrespect for constitution,
for parliamentary
democratic system and so on.
And who is the speaker of the house?
You have Donald Trump openly advocating public disorder
and so on and so on.
So I think all this talk about the end of the
American empire,
it's predominantly
a matter of what happens in America itself.
And what really worries me is that
in different forums,
it's happening all around the world.
Here in the UK,
I simplify it up to the utmost,
but you probably noticed
that you no longer have a leftist party.
You have a moderate,
moderate Conservative Party.
It's called Labour Party. No,
yeah, that sounds right party now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then you have extreme
freakish right wingers now,
you know, and uh,
the problem is that
this extremely freakish right wingers are
maybe they believe in
continue to knows what will happen with Farage
and so on and so on.
You have in France
similar tendency in Germany
alternative for Germany growing
and so on and so on. So
I Think it's the tendency today.
It's towards.
I'm still afraid to use the term,
but towards a kind of.
I don't have a concept, but
kind of a new forum of fascism.
Fascist capitalism.
Not fascism necessarily in that Nazi sense,
but in the sense of strong nation state.